right so here is a second fallacy that i
showed you
and um it was pretty neat because you
know i could bring negatives into there
or you could add one to both sides and
show that two is equal to zero which is
even more confusing than two b equal to
one at least they're both positive
what's wrong with this okay now i've
numbered the lines all again so you can
identify
there are a couple of places um that
people saw that there were problems
right
now most people can see if you have a
look at five six and seven
right once you get to line five it's
pretty much over
i've already gotten it all sewn up
because line five lines
six slide seven nothing dramatic happens
um
what happens in here you're just
evaluating numbers you can use a
calculator to check if you don't trust
those
um values for the trig ratios okay from
here to here just
in the same way nothing very much
dramatic takes place one minus zero
pretty sure is one the square root is
one okay
so what's going wrong here okay clearly
it's earlier than line five
so the most natural explanation for
where this is gone funny
is um up here in line four so people say
yeah
there's a problem okay um theta is equal
to 180 degrees and
most people think i'm on to something
because the original proof i gave you
for this result use this triangle
right so if you have theta down here and
you make the hypotenuse
one then you're going to have sine theta
over here cos
theta over here use that for pythagoras
but aha
theta equals 180 can't happen in this
triangle actually it can't happen in any
triangle
because the whole angle sum has to equal
180 degrees you can't have
180 degrees of one and then zero degrees
for the yellow zero degrees for the
other angle
that's not a triangle okay so most
people think aha
this must be the issue okay now that's
close but no cigar the reason why is
that
you might recall i told you this was a
kind of a cheap and nasty way to prove
this identity but this identity is
actually true
for all values of theta um any value you
throw in there no matter how big it is
like even if it's 500 degrees which
can't even fit the triangle
it'll still work okay and you can check
this out right um you can pop
the 100 degrees up into here and verify
that sine 180 degrees is zero and
cos theta is negative one so when you
square it you get one so sure enough
it's one okay so where's the issue now
lots of people said to me okay i know
it's not four but something sneaky is
happening between line two and my three
there should be a plus or minus okay
there should be a plus or minus
but this then raised the question of
most people couldn't explain to me
why should they be a plus or minus like
they knew it's because something to do
with the square root
but like why i mean they didn't say
if i gave you this and this is the
example i actually um sent to people
right i've got two things that they're
equal their problems
right so that's 25 right and that's i'll
just leave that as 5 squared
now if i take the square root of both
sides right you wouldn't say
5 equals plus or minus 5 right but this
line here looks very similar to this
you've got no plus minus there the
positive value
right then you go plus or minus on here
well clearly 5 is not equal to negative
5.
so if you're not going to put a plus or
minus there why would you bother to put
one over there
but here's why okay um the reason why
this doesn't make sense to put a plus or
minus
on this equation right but on this one
is that unlike five cos theta is not
just
any ordinary number i gave you a clue
about this when i showed you the graph
of what cos looked like before it looks
like this
that's 360 degrees okay there's 180 in
the middle
cos theta is not just any number you can
see in between 90 degrees and 270
degrees
cos is negative right you might even
remember this from your arm
from your quadrants diagram see positive
here
positive here but not there okay so
therefore
this line to this line is a bit sneaky
right it is plus or minus
depending on what value of theta you
actually put into there
okay so that's why there's an issue kind
of with here but only because of what we
said in the previous line
and that's how you can come up with
nonsensical results like that